nun geht es weiter mit der Frage ob die
nächste terrorismuswelle droht und ob
nennt sie Feser ja ihren Job eigentlich
gut macht das wird uns jetzt Frank
Schneider präsentieren ja genau es ist
wirklich eine große Terrorgefahr die
möglicherweise in den nächsten Monaten
oder auch Jahren auf uns zu rollt wir
sehen ja hier auch noch mal wirklich
schreckliche Bilder und wir haben es ja
zum Glück teilweise fast schon wieder
verdrängt was in Paris passiert ist in
Brüssel in anderen in Manchester damals
der Bombenanschlag auch in London und es
hat sich ja zum Glück etwas beruhigt das
sind natürlich auch damit zusammen dass
die ersten Teilen besiegt und bekämpft
wurde in Syrien das in Afghanistan die
Amerikaner lange vor Ort waren und jetzt
passiert genau das was die Geheimdienste
das sogenannte erhöhte Grundrauschen
nehmen das klingt erstmal harmlos aber
dieses erhöhte Grundrauschen bedeutet
nichts anderes als erhöhte
Anschlagsgefahr erhöhte Terrorgefahr
erhöhte anschlagsbereitschaft wir sehen
hier auch Bilder aus Castrop-Rauxel dort
wurde Anfang des Jahres ein
Terroranschlag geplant wir hatten den
letzten Tagen in Hamburg
selbstmordatentäter die mit
sprengstoffgürteln offenbar Anschläge
begehen wollten wir hatten jetzt in
Duisburg Facebook ein
selbstradikalisierten offenbar
Einzeltäter der im Fitnessstudio als
Menschen angegriffen hat hinterher kommt
raus er hat schon einen Menschen zwei
Wochen vorher erstochen auch offenbar
für den is und wir müssen da unglaublich
aufpassen und was ganz brisant ist an
der Situation der ukraine-konflikt kommt
diesen Terroristen zu Nutze denn über
die Ukraine kommen viele Menschen
überfordert asienbereich Tadschikistan
kirgisin und ähnliches und da gibt es
eine neue Gruppierung die nennt sich
islamischer Staat in der Provinz Provinz
Cora San und das sind sehr sehr
brandgefährliche Menschen und was macht
Frau Faser sie schwächt jetzt die
Bundespolizei mit der Novellierung des
bundespolizeigesetzes und sagt
Polizisten an der Grenze wenn da
Menschen kommen die
Migrationshintergrund haben migrantisch
aussehen dann dürfte die eigentlich
nicht kontrollieren das ist racial
Profiling außer ihr stellt eine
kontrollquittung aus dass die Menschen
sich hinter beschweren können dass sie
kontrolliert wurden und das macht
natürlich in so einer Situation die
Sache nicht besser
herr Meyer da muss ich natürlich direkt
zu ihnen blinken teilen Sie die
Auffassung von Frau Feser ne diese Thema
quittungsausstellen ist natürlich schon
Punkt wo wir auch geschluckt haben
andererseits müssen wir uns natürlich
auch da ein Stück weit ehrlich machen
also wir sind in dieser Koalition wo in
der Tat zwei Partner das Thema special
Profiling sehr hoch
gewichtet haben und das Ausstellen
dieser Quittung die ja letztlich eine
Begründung dafür darstellen Kontrollen
durchzuführen war in dem jetzigen
entwurftes
bundespolizeigesetzes in Kompromiss der
aber glaube ich schon im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal auf
praktischer Kapazität geprüft werden wir
müssen noch ehrlich sein
aber am Ende des Tages ist es doch so
also wir haben
Diskussion darüber wie praktikabel das
ist und ich glaube in der Tat die
Position dazu ist eigentlich relativ ein
sehr deutlich bei den Experten und dazu
ist ein parlamentarisches Verfahren dann
ja auch da dass in Expertenanhörungen
und so weiter das gegebenenfalls den
Einfluss in einen Gesetze sie sitzen
gerade bildchef Reporter Frank Schneider
entgegen und der spricht klar von einer
Terrorgefahr da muss ich Ihnen sagen als
Bürgerin empfinde ich Ihre Antwort jetzt
nicht als
Trost bringen
wird ja nicht durch das Ausstellen einer
Quittung um die es geht jetzt maßgeblich
reduziert und am Ende des Tages haben
wir eine Terrorgefahr die seit 2015
wächst in diesem Land wir müssen über
ganz ganz viele Versäumnisse reden z.B
auch über die Versäumnisse auf der
Landesebene wir müssen darüber reden
dass die Informationsfluss zwischen den
einzelnen Behörden besser wird auch
daran arbeiten wir deswegen ist das ein
Thema wo wir ganz ganz viele Themen uns
angucken müssen die Novelle die jetzt
angeschoben ist was das Bundespolizei
gesetzt angeht hat nach meiner
Auffassung sprechen so da muss man noch
mal gucken
Käse hat schon beschlossene Gelder nicht
weitergeliefert Personal geht kommt bei
der Bundespolizei nicht an und die
kontrollquittung auch wenn sie sagen das
erhöht das Risiko nicht überlegen Sie
doch mal sie sind ein Bundespolizist an
der Grenze sie möchten noch ober oder
Hauptkommissar werden und wenn sie jetzt
ihrem rechtsstaatlichen Auftrag der ist
es ja eigentlich nachkommen und
kontrollieren Menschen über die Grenze
kommen und jetzt auch mal zum Thema
racial Profiling wen soll ich denn an
der Grenze kontrollieren wenn ich nicht
den offensichtlichen Migranten
kontrollieren darf der möglicherweise
illegal einreist das Rentnerpärchen aus
Brandenburg was auch im Urlaub kommt
nein so also muss ich doch den Migranten
kontrollieren wenn ich den aber
kontrolliere setze ich mich diesen
Generalverdacht ich verstehe sowieso
nicht woher dieser Generalverdacht gegen
Polizisten in diesem Land kommt aus der
Regierung neuerdings äh setze ich mich
dem vorwurface Profiling aus und jetzt
noch der letzte Satz und dann sagt
dieser Polizist doch ich
Disziplinarverfahren warum kontrolliere
ich Dir nicht was eigentlich mein
Auftrag ist ich kein Ärger nein
rechtlichen gesetzlichen Auftrag nach
riskiere ich ein Disziplinarverfahren
was würden Sie jetzt machen
sich doch durchaus Bayern sie haben noch
das Problem gerade zu treffen
beschrieben wir haben einen zumindest
hergestellt Designs dass ich natürlich
wenn ich in diese Kontrolle Quittung
reinschreibe warum ich jemanden
kontrolliere und wenn Sie gerade das
Thema Terrorgefahr aus aus Asien
irgendwo beschrieben haben was die die
quasi rote angeht nach Deutschland über
die Ukraine dann haben wir eine
Situation wo sie damit natürlich eine
Begründung haben weswegen sie jemanden
kontrollieren können deswegen geht es
ist halt nur die Frage ob es praktikabel
ist nach meiner Auffassung ist es nicht
praktikabel ich bin kein innen und
rechts Politiker aber als ich das
gelesen habe deswegen sagte ich hatte
ein oder andere bei uns eine Fraktion
auch geschlagen haben das werden wir uns
noch mal angucken so
schlucken sehr viele in der Koalition ja
andere also wenn Sie wenn Sie unsere
Koalitionspartner
anhören würden die schlucken auch sehr
viel weil wir natürlich als FDP auch
Haushalt Finanzpolitik Heizungs Thema
ebenfalls momentan immer wo die Bremse
Demokratie fördergesetz all die ganzen
eine ganz ganz viele
biotop-themen reden wo wir ziemlich hart
auf die Bremse gehen in
unterschiedlichen in unterschiedlichen
quasi Stadien der das
Gesetzgebungsverfahrens und hier ist es
leider auch so ein Thema wir müssen
einfach festhalten dass in dieser
Koalition das wäre bei Jamaika übrigens
auch so nach der letzten Bundestagswahl
gewesen Grüne und FDP oftmals diametral
unterschiedliche programmsätze haben und
das müssen wir jetzt in Übereinklang
bringen und deswegen freuen wir uns
darauf diesen Entwurf noch besser zu
verstehen
aber meines Wissens sozialdemokrates und
ja das ist richtig ja dann bin ich jetzt
an einem Punkt warum an zwei Punkten
erstens weiß ich nicht was besondere
liberale Haltung ist wenn man der
Polizei ihren Job verliert zu machen wir
haben einen Migrationsdruck wir lesen
jeden Tag und hören jeden Tag dass die
Kommunen die lange die Landwirte ja ich
nehme es nur mit dem Gedanken weg
sozusagen nicht mehr zu rangekommen
aber wir blockieren alles was halbwegs
vernünftiges und nicht garantiere Ihnen
eins der Wähler draußen sagt sind die
eigentlich irre warum lassen sie die
alle rein sollen ja Leute reinkommen
aber bitte kontrolliert doch mal richtig
so aber das ist also liberal dass die
FDP dies wieder irgendwie doch toleriert
dann muss man auch mal sagen so geht es
nicht zweiter Punkt wieso eigentlich
macht die SPD solche Politik es sind
doch ihre Bürgermeister und Landräte
meines Wissens haben die ja noch ein
paar aber das muss man negiert das und
das ist ja ihre Agenda das ist ja mal
knallert sagen ihre Agenda sie spricht
im Bundestag korrigiert sie sich aber da
hat sie sich sozusagen verplappert
Beweislast Umkehr bei Polizisten in
disziplinarecht dann geht's noch weiter
sie negiert diese migrationskrise sie
hat im letzten Jahr zahlen schön
gerechnet ich will immer ein Beispiel
ändern damit sie mal wissen wie er
Koalitionspartner agiert da hat sie
einfach bei der Bundespolizei folgendes
gemacht wenn ein Migrant illegal direkt
bei der Einreise einer Grenze
festgestellt wurde Fingern die Statistik
hatte aber er bereits einen Zug
bestiegen und war ein paar Kilometer
lang Einsatz gefahren oder gelaufen dann
galt er nicht mehr als illegal
eingereist aber ja schon im Land war so
rechnet man sich Zahlen schön und das
ist bei Frau Feser zieht sich das wie
ein roter Faden dadurch dass sie alle
Probleme negiert der Polizei wirklich
Knüppel zwischen die Beine wirft und ich
verstehe bis heute nicht welche Agenda
diese Frau hat und ein letzter Satz
fangen sie mal die ganzen
landesinnminister in vielen koalitionen
sind sie ja nicht aber fragen Sie mal
rum die verzweifeln alle an dieser
Person weil das was sie erzählt und was
sie macht entsteht diametral entgegen
aber die Landes Innenminister sind doch
auch durchaus Teil des Themas also wenn
ich mir zum Beispiel Nordrhein-Westfalen
angucke schwarz grüne Koalition wenn wir
uns angucken was dort im Bereich
Sicherheitspolitik in letzter Jahr
passiert
also ich sag mal Bekämpfung von Clank
Kriminalität habe ich den letzten
Monaten in dieser Koalition nicht mehr
wahrgenommen ist eigentlich eher so wie
immer Koalition aber
das Problem vielschichtig ich will ja
ich weigere mich nur dass da muss ich in
Bremer widersprechen wenn ich den
Eindruck erweckt dass wir quasi da
weitermachen als Ampel wo ähm wo
vielleicht Angela Merkel
2015/2016 aufgehört hat und am Ende des
Tages das ist ja mein Thema da kommen
wir sicherlich gleich zu dass wir die
Migration ab in die Runde ich muss hier
der Dame in der Runde immer ein bisschen
Redezeit verschaffen jetzt ist natürlich
meine Frage an Sie wie geht es ihnen
wenn sie das alles hören auch als
BürgerInnen also ich frage mich
tatsächlich genauso wie sie was
eigentlich Frau Feser reitet was ihre
Agenda ist ich will wer wirklich mega
interessiert das mal rauszufinden weil
ich finde dass sie seit sie im Amt ist
so merkwürdig agiert dass man sich
wirklich fragt was also was ist das Ziel
dieser Frau und das ich frage mich auch
ist sie überhaupt noch in unserem
Rechtsstaat zu Hause also hat sie
irgendwie noch ein Bewusstsein dafür
dass zum Beispiel diese Beweis lässt um
bei Polizeibeamten
haarsträubend ist oder auch in der
Migrationspolitik in der
Migrationspolitik muss man allerdings
sagen das war auch schon vor Frau Feser
ich finde es ist noch schlimmer geworden
mit Frau Felser aber das war schon
vorher so dass der Rechtsstaat
eigentlich immer wieder einfach
ignoriert wurde weil man weil man nicht
dafür gesorgt hat dass das wirklich die
Abkommen die auch ja schon seit Jahren
bestehen sozusagen mit den
EU-Außengrenzen dass die überhaupt nicht
eingehalten werden das je diejenigen die
sagen wir mal
illegal nach Deutschland gekommen sind
nicht zurückgeführt werden das heißt man
man ignoriert geltendes gerecht
Entschuldigung man ignoriert geltendes
Recht und das seit Jahren und Frau Feser
treibt es eigentlich noch auf die Spitze
und wenn wenn ich es bestimmen könnte
müsste Frau Feser eigentlich sofort
zurückgeben weil sie einen
katastrophalen Job machen